we have just signed the third NATO EU
joint declaration
to further Advance the Strategic
partnership between NATO and the
European Union this is more important
than ever
almost a year ago
hours after Russia's invasion of Ukraine
on the 24th of February
the three of us met together here at the
NATO headquarters
President Putin wanted to take Ukraine
in a few days and to divide us
on both counts he has clearly failed
Russian troops have been pushed back by
the brave Ukrainian forces and NATO and
the European Union have stood United in
support of Ukraine
the regime in Moscow wants wants a
different Europe
it wants to control its neighbors and it
sees democracy and freedom as a threat
this will have a long lasting
consequences for our security
so we must continue to strengthen the
vital transatlantic bond in NATO we must
continue to strengthen the partnership
between NATO and the European Union and
we must further strengthen our support
to Ukraine
in the world of growing strategic
competition
authoritarian actors challenge our
interests values and Democratic
principles
through military but also political
economic and technological means
China's growing a certainness and
policies present challenges that we need
to address
persistent conflict and instability in
our neighborhood undermine our security
and provide fertile ground for both
strategic competitors and terrorist
groups
our declaration makes clear that NATO
Remains the foundation of our collected
events and remains essential for
euro-atlantic security
it also recognizes the value of a more
capable European Defense that
contributes positively to our security
and is complementary to and
interoperable with NATO today's
declaration Builds on the previous two
from 2016 and 2018.
based on these declarations we have
developed concrete actions and we have
reached unprecedented progress in our
cooperation
we are determined to take the
partnership between NATO and the
European Union to the next level
to address in particular the growing
geostrategic competition resilience
issues and the protection of critical
infrastructures as well as emerging and
disruptive Technologies space
the security implications of climate
change
for interference and information
manipulation
our partnership will become even more
important once Finland and Sweden become
full NATO members
with their accession NATO will be
protecting 96 of the citizens in the
European Union and a higher share of its
territory than ever before
we encourage the fullest possible
involvement of the NATO allies that are
not members of the EU in its initiatives
and we encourage the fullest possible
involvement of EU members that are not
part of the alliance in its initiatives
Charles thank you for your personal
commitment and your leadership in taking
our cooperation forward so then I passed
the floor to you president Michelle
ladies and gentlemen good morning
allies make strong alliances the
European Union in NATO we have evolved
and grown in parallel over the years our
organizations are close our histories
are intertwined 21 of the 27 EU member
states are member of NATO and 23 if we
count Sweden and Finland and EU member
states represent the majority of NATO
countries
the EU and NATO we share the same common
values of freedom and democracy and we
share the same goal peace freedom and
prosperity for our people
Russia swore against Ukraine has had two
unintended consequences it has
strengthened both our organizations the
EU and NATO and it has brought us closer
together
first we are stronger NATO has to
enforce its presence in Eastern Europe
and it will have two new members Sweden
and Finland
putting wanted less NATO but he has
achieved the opposite he will have more
NATO and he will have more EU we are
also getting stronger we are speeding up
the enlargement process with the Western
Balkans and we took the historic
decision to Grant candidate statues to
Ukraine and Moldova and the European
perspective to Georgia and we are
enforcing our European Defense for the
first time in history we provided little
military equipment to Ukraine through
our European peace facility just a few
hours after the start of the war so far
we have reached more than 3 billion
euros in addition to the massive
military contributions of Our member
states
since day one we have stood by the
people of Ukraine with strong military
Financial diplomatic and political
support together the EU and its member
states have contributed to nearly 50
billion euros
incidents Russia sword against Ukraine
has brought the EU and NATO closer
together in fact we are closer today
than ever both our organizations have
recently raised our ambition by
upgrading our strategies for our future
security the EU strategic campus and
NATO strategic Concepts our
organizations are complementary NATO
isync Remains the foundation of
collective defense and essential to
euro-atlantic security and the EU is
determined to contribute more
effectively to Global and residential
security
with today's declaration we want to take
our cooperation to the next level to
ensure peace and stability
intensified our cooperation in new areas
such as protecting critical
infrastructure space the secret
implications of climate change and
foreign information manipulation and
interference
we Europeans we want to take more
responsibility for our defense and that
also means we enforcing the European
pillar within NATO
EU leaders agreed on a clear strategy at
our meeting in Versailles last year in
March we developed a strategy to bolster
our strategic autonomy and European
sovereignty we agreed to spend more on
defense and to strengthen our industrial
capabilities by investing to more in our
defense
making Europe stronger makes NATO
stronger because strong allies made
strong reliances
thank you again the audience for your
commitment in taking this cooperation
forward you can count on the EU thank
you thanks so much and then I give the
floor to present from the line please
thank you very much
indeed I will never forget this 24th of
February of last year when the three of
us were standing here the day that
Russia launched its brutal invasion of
Ukraine and it was a very strong signal
of unity and of determination and with
the same unity and determination we're
here today again for the James joints
statement the eyes of the world were
locked on Ukraine's Eastern Front last
year when the Russia started the war but
they were also looking at us here in
Brussels
scrutinizing our preparation and our
reactions and that day the world saw how
strongly united we were and we still are
together in the support of the Ukrainian
people but also against Russia's
Imperial War
since then our unity and resolve have
only grown stronger we have already been
very close partners of course before
Russia's brutal War so we have been
testing and coordinating our crisis
responses through many many exercises
we've had together we have increased our
cooperation against cyber attacks for
better military Mobility to fight this
information or by addressing the hybrid
attacks against Latvia Poland and
Lithuania organized by the lukashenko
regime I remember a joint travel to the
region with unions
by the times we're living in
um we know that we have to strengthen
that now deepen this more than 20 year
old partnership
because Europe's security is challenged
and it is under threat and this is also
reflected in the wish of Sweden and
Finland to join NATO we look very much
forward to Sweden and Finland becoming
NATO members soon it's also reflected in
Denmark's abolishment of the opt-out
Clause related to EU defense all these
shows we are aware of the challenge but
we're able to stand up against it
the Russian threats and challenges are
the most immediate but they are not the
only ones
we also witnessed China increasingly
attempting to reshape the international
order to its benefits
so we must bolster our own resilience
and with this new joint declaration
we're also taking our partnership to the
next level
we will deepen our excellent cooperation
and expand it to New areas
I would like to look at four of them
very briefly
the first one is that we will further
intensify our work on countering hybrid
threats and cyber threats as well as
terrorism we have already a very close
cooperation but we want to broaden and
deepen it
the second is we will step up
cooperation on emerging and disruptive
technology and space we do a lot already
together but we can do much more
the third
domain is we will address the looming
security implication of the climate
crisis sounds a bit far away but we are
fully aware that with the climate crisis
and the extreme weather events like
droughts and floods
um we see more and more the phenomenal
phenomenon of fostering instability with
all the consequences of poverty of
unrest of instability of whole regions
and therefore this is also a point of
focus for us together
and the fourth point of course we will
strengthen our resilience the resilience
of our societies against malign foreign
interference to manipulate information
and crucially the resilience of our
critical infrastructure
against all types of attack the north
stream sabotage has shown that we need
to take more responsibility for the
security of our Network infrastructure
and they are too we are aware that the
individual countries are responsible for
the security of this infrastructure and
for sure we will not share
vulnerabilities but best practices
experiences
this is a field where we can work closer
together and we will intensify the
cooperation
the European Union will keep doing
everything in its power to support the
brave people of Ukraine we will keep the
pressure on the Kremlin for as long as
it takes with the biting sanctions
regime
we will extend these sanctions to those
who militarily support Russia's War such
as Belarus
or Iran
and we will be coming forward with new
sanctions on Belarus answering their
Belarus roles role in this Russian war
in Ukraine
we will continue our substantial
humanitarian economic and security
assistance to Ukraine um as long as it
is necessary
and of course there's a topic to boost
European Defense capabilities as laid
out in the Strategic compass
for that we all know that now we need to
ramp up the production capacity of our
defense industry
and we need to coordinate the
replenishment of military equipment on
all these topics I looked forward to
working with the prime minister of
christerson under the Swedish presidency
of the Council of the European Union and
of course we will discuss this and much
more tomorrow with you yens when you
will be visiting the college many things
okay we'll start with Financial Times
over there
uh thank you so much
um Henry 500 times the question for
president Michelle
um last in October 2021 you said that
2022 would be the year of European
Defense you said there would be
strengthening of strategic autonomy uh
to reduce Reliance on others today
you've designed a document that says
stronger European armies are
complementary to Nato as the leader in
that is true strategic autonomy dead or
has it just been put on the shelf for a
few more years and if I may a question
for the Secretary General uh we've heard
from the swedes and the Finns that they
think they've done enough and turkey
should not ask for more do you agree
does turkey have a right to ask for more
steps or or has been in Finland
completely done all they can for
membership thank you
let me take the question about uh
strategic autonomy let me make it clear
that this is of the essence and
continues to be so and the European
Council has defined the framework for
this uh strategy for this autonomy in
March in Versailles there are three
pillars which are absolutely crucial in
which I fully support the first pillow
pillar is a energy sovereignty we're not
discussing this here because that is not
a topic of the day but it's something
that we work on in the Commission in the
council in order to have
a real uh Market single Market here and
have more Independence and sovereignty
regarding this matter the second pillar
is that of defense and security and this
is where the Strategic concept NATO's
strategic concept
complements supports and is consistent
with another strategic document which is
the EU document the Strategic compass
this does demonstrate that this topic is
extremely important to us
and with this in mind I would add that
let us not forget that the overnight
between the 23rd and the 24th of
February when President zielinski called
us a number of us were there and at EU
was able to very rapidly activate its
peace facility in order to provide
weapons to a country to Ukraine and I
think that this is
in a way that the birth of a European
Defense in a very effective Manner and
then there's also technological
sovereignty there's a more of an
economic approach which we did not
discuss today so just to confirm that
this whole notion of autonomy of
Independence is a very important in
order to have more resilience going
forward and it is quite clear that this
is something which needs to be done in
complementarity with our friends
partners and allies and we do this with
NATO and I said this at the time and I
would repeat that today
strong allies create solid alliances and
that is what we're doing today we are
reinforcing the EU we're reinforcing
NATO and this reinforces our unity in
the face of a threat which we are
dealing with because of this war which
was started by Russia
and the membership of NATO in NATO
I'm confident that the accession process
will be finalized and that uh and that
all NATO analyzers will ratify the
accession protocols in the parliaments
and and that also goes for turkey
but let me start by just reminding you
all about what has happened so far
this has been so far the quickest
accession process in NATO's modern
history we have to remember that
normally accession processes into NATO
takes years
uh Finland Sweden applied in May last
year already in July all 30 allies
including turkey
decided to invite Finance Sweden to
become full members of NATO and all 30
allies also signed the accession
protocols and so far 20 28 out of 30
allies have already ratified this is
quicker than ever before in NATO's
modern history
um then uh what paved the way for this
uh historic decision was the agreement
between turkey Finland and Sweden that
was also assigned on the margins of the
NATO Summit in Madrid in July where they
agreed to work more closer together
Finance with agrees to lift the
restrictions on arms exports that has
already been done and they also agreed
to work more closely in the fight
against terrorism that that is also
taking place they have established a
permanent mechanism where they exchange
more information intelligence and and
they are working more closely in in how
to address terrorist threats turkey has
legitimate security concerns no NATO
Ally has suffered more terrorist attacks
than a turkey and therefore it is
something which is welcomed that the
NATO allies Finland Sweden are working
can work closely on these these issues
and then let me add one more thing and
that is that we have to understand that
Finland and Sweden they are in a very
different place now uh compared to where
they were before they applied for a NATO
membership since they applied several
NATO allies including the United States
have agreed a bilateral security
Arrangements security assurances for
Finland and Sweden NATO has increased
its presence in the region and as
invitees Finland and Sweden are now
participating in NATO's meetings
ministerial meetings ambassadora
meetings meetings of different NATO
committees and um and and finance
Vietnam War and more integrated into
NATO's military structures
so it's inconceivable that Finland and
Sweden will face any military threat
without NATO reacting to that so I'm
saying that I I of course see the
importance of finalizing the accession
process with the ratification in both
the Hungarian and the Turkish Parliament
but I'm also saying that I'm confident
that will happen and that we have
already moved a very long way in a short
time with Finland and Sweden
then I've had a few words on the topic
of strategic autonomy a lot has happened
in the last year
and president Michelle is right when he
said that at the beginning of the year
because strategic autonomy is not only
limited to defense it includes of course
defense
and strategic autonomy does not say that
you do not cooperate you cooperate with
like-minded partners
and the fields in which we have made a
lot of progress the first one is very
well known and this is the vaccine
production so I don't have to explain
that but a big step forward on that
we've done during the pandemic
the second field indeed is or was our
toxic dependency on Russian fossil fuels
We have basically completely gotten rid
of it during this year coal completely
we have wind down a Russian oil and more
than 80 percent of the Russian gas has
been cut we have been able and that
strategic autonomy to diversify
our supply chains to trusted and
like-minded partners
and of course to ramp up the own
production of energy we have doubled the
deployment of additional renewable
energy in the European Union and this is
Independence renewable energy is not
only clean and affordable but
Independence
then we have been working because we saw
a growing dependency on semiconductors
on the chips act also a success story
we are preparing the raw materials act
because we see the same
um challenge what the supply of raw
material is concerned too much focused
on one region of the world
and we have developed global gateway
also to build up these Partnerships with
like-minded on the whole energy topic
for example with the global South so a
lot has happened in the topic of
strategic autonomy final Point defense
we are working now with the member
states through a task force jointly with
the eeas and the European Defense Agency
to figure out what are the needs for the
replenishment of the stocks and what
does the industry need to cater for it
because it takes two here not only the
demand but also of course the supply
side and this is another step forward in
organizing and harmonizing a European
common defense answer
okay we'll go to the Ukrainian news
agency Ukraine form
thank you foreign
I want to mention that ukrainians are
grateful uh very much to both
organization both to EU and NATO for
practical solidarity my question is that
the both organizations now have the
common problem of depletion of military
stocks because nobody expected the war
in Ukraine of such a scale my question
is what is the Practical cooperation
between NATO and EU in filling that Gap
and the second part of the question as
the Russian now mobilized reservists and
preparing some kind of a future Advance
will EU and NATO be able to be in time
and prepared to assist Ukraine in these
battle which could be decisive thank you
maybe I could start by saying that you
are right that NATO allies and EU
members have depleted their stocks to
provide support to Ukraine and that has
been the right thing to do because this
is also about our security and of course
we need to use our uh
capabilities our stocks our ammunition
to support Ukraine and I've also been
asked and I've told NATO allies that if
they had to choose between meeting all
the NATO guidelines on stocks on
capabilities or to support Ukraine it's
more important to support Ukraine uh and
um and and therefore we have been able
to provide a unprecedented level of
support to Ukraine over many months but
of course uh when we are depleting our
stocks there is only one long-term uh
solution to that and that is to produce
more uh and uh that's also reason why
NATO defense ministers took decisions to
increase our stockpiles of Munitions and
Equipment when they met
last fall we have also a long-standing
defense planning process and capability
targets for each and every Ally
including stocks and ammunition and we
are revising them to ensure that we have
enough stocks both to protect our own
territory but also to provide support
for Ukraine and we are also working with
the European Union we had a commissioner
here just before Christmas and and we
are on the staff level looking into how
we can coordinate our efforts and
because this is about ramping of
production of course in EU NATO allies
but also in allies that are not the
members of the European Union and we
have engaged directly within the state
and they are now ramping up production
the aim is of course to ensure that we
can continue and also strengthen our
support to Ukraine because we have seen
that Russia has
suffered uh uh big losses in in Ukraine
due to the brave Ukrainian soldiers
under and the professionalism and
education of the Ukrainian Armed Forces
but we should not underestimate Russia
they are mobilizing more troops they are
working hard to acquire more equipment
more ammunition and they are shown a
willingness to actually suffer but
continue the war and there is no
indication that President Putin has
changed the overall aim of his uh brutal
war against Ukraine so we need to be
prepared for the Long Haul we need to
continue to support Ukraine and again it
is a a extremely important message that
we're sending today with the Declaration
with the two presidents hair present
with me that we stand United
NATO and the European Union in our
support to Ukraine
we're running out of time but we'll take
one third question which is a DPA
thank you how's the German press agency
DPA a great question to all of you on
the ongoing discussions on weapon
deliveries to Ukraine do you support
member states that are considering
sending Western main battle tanks like
the Leo part 2 or the Challenger 2 to
Ukraine or do you feel that there's a
huge risk of escalation thank you
I have said many times since the
beginning of Russia's invasion in
Ukraine that I think that Ukraine should
God get all the necessary military
equipment they need and they can handle
to defend their Homeland and this means
of course Advanced Air Defense systems
but also other types of advanced
military equipment as long as it is
necessary to defend Ukraine because they
also defend the basic principles of the
U.N Charter of the fundamental rights
and of the international law and I've
said that at the very beginning of
Russia's war and I have still this
position of course
let me just add that um
that what you have seen is that
we NATO allies EU members have uh
provided a Ukraine also with Advanced
weapon systems since the war started and
I welcome the new announcements uh just
lost the days by the United States
Germany France to also provide new types
of
um of armored vehicles
infantry fighting vehicles and other
types of armor to to Ukraine this is
important there is a constant
consultation within the alliance between
the NATO allies but also with Ukraine
we'll meet next week in Ramstein in the
U.S led contact group to provide support
to Ukraine and they will meet with the
Ukrainian defense minister to discuss
exactly what types of weapons are needed
and how can allies provide those weapons
so so in addition to armor we have also
provided Advanced Air Defense systems as
president Von Ryan Russell just refer to
and also long-range missiles with the
high Mars and and all these systems are
making a huge difference on the
battlefield every day
I welcome the focus on systems but I
think we need to also realize that this
is not only about adding more systems
more platforms more weapons but also
ensuring that the platforms the weapons
we have already provided are working as
they should meaning that we also need to
ensure that we provide the necessary
ammunition the spare parts the training
the maintenance of the systems which are
already provided and therefore yes it is
important to address what new systems do
we need to provide to Ukraine but also
to ensure that all the systems which are
already there are working as they should
there is a there is an addresser there
is a Kremlin and there is a victim this
is the people of Ukraine and I'm very
pleased that uh in the in the recent
weeks and months following the start of
the war the the member states were able
to deliver more and more military
equipment to to Ukraine and uh like
osula said I fully support the same
approach and the European Council many
times repeated the the call on more
military support for Ukraine or to make
sure that they will be able to to defend
their side because we know that the
fighting for the future but they are
also fighting for our common values
thank you very much I'm sorry we can't
take all the questions we have but this
concludes this press conference thank
you
[Music]